nate pearson as we've talked about will
make his fourth big league start here
tonight
what a season he's having anthony
santander riding a 12-game hit streak
two hits last night 2-2 pitch to
santander
that's wrapped way back and that one
is gone is that utah street that's gotta
be
the worst one hop at the warehouse
anthony santander with a two-run shot
his eighth of the year
young nate you can't live right there
that's the no-fly zone for me
and he turns it around quickly and i
mean way out to straight away right
field
up on the rooftop gucci knocked up his
first time up
driven to deep left field and grechik
will
stay hot a two-run shot to tie the game
his
third straight game with a home run it's
a change up
not a bad pitch down and look at how his
head stays down on this this is a
terrific
swing so a brand new game tied at two
and here's santander
the one two santander swings and drives
the ball out towards center field alfred
heads back he looks
and this one is gone it's another home
run
santander i mean i thought the center
fielder alfred had a chance to catch it
and he did too
it closed with this ball just yeah this
ball just grabbed another gear about
three quarters way out there and it got
out
blue jays have runners on the corner
with nobody down
kevin biggio comes to the plate
that wasn't it takes slow ball four an
infield single an opposite field single
and now a walk
nobody out for randall gridsick the
pitch
swinging a line drive in the air out to
right field touched pretty well pushing
santander back
and it hits high off the wall and kicks
back towards shallow right field
alfred is in to tie the game espinal
will come in to score
bishop ends up at third and two runs are
in on a ringing base hit by randall
gritship two balls and one strike
the left-handed hitting travis shaw
now shaw lifts one deep right
center field and it is gone
three run shot and a huge inning for the
blue chase in baltimore
well that was a no doubter he had a
couple of good swings against
the lefty and then he sees the right
hand right-hander and for
shaw his third home run of the season
the blue jays go back to back
two balls two strikes to cisco
hit well way back and right field chance
cisco just took one out of the ballpark
and this thing got a little tighter 7-5
chance cisco in the d-h spot delivers we
talked about the oriole catchers what
they have done
third homer for chance cisco
here's rio ruiz
the o2 this is smashed out towards left
field and deep
this ball is off the bottom of the fence
mccarran played by guriel throw into
second on one hop
ruiz slides in safely ball gets away
towards the orioles dugout
and ruiz jogs to third base
here come the orioles in the fifth
guriel quickly gets this ball and fires
a
dart in and he gets away
rio quickly takes another 90 feet
fly ball left field they should get him
home
guriel back it's a fair ball
ruiz coming home oh big throw
wow they made it close pretty good throw
from guriel he
let it go not only was it a strong throw
guriel gets this ball out of his glove
in his throwing hand in just a
millisecond it seems like in through a
dart and if janssen's able to come up
with that ball and that's a tough chance
because the ball kicked really high on
him but
the throw actually beat ruiz home watch
how fast i mean in the glove and out
and just an accurate throw all the way
home but it short hops jansson just a
tough chance for him
and there's an intentional walk to
dwight smith four and now the bags are
loaded alberto
why not catch it
rip down to third what a play by shaw
throws across the infield and he doesn't
get him
one runs in the orioles have tied this
game
santander steps in
it will left center field gap carrying
and it short hops the wall santander
round second
juggled out there by guriel comes up
with it and anthony santander has his
third extra base hit of the game two
homers and now a double ruiz steps in
popped up left side in play
shaw grabs it to end the inning two for
four
diving stop by davis he's coming home
with the ball and it bounces away
and the blue jays catch an enormous
break
as they take the lead down to their
final out here
3-2 again popped it up
and the blue jays find a way to win the
game
it wasn't the prettiest win of the
season to buck but it's a w and they'll
take it